Локдаун, зумовлений коронавірусом, коштував очікуваного заробітку
тисячам українських трудових мігрантів.
Розчаровані ті, хто розраховував на сезонні роботи в ЄС.
Особливо ж не пощастило тим, хто, вже маючи необхідні документи,
не міг перетнути кордон. Електрик із Вінничини Андрій Мельник
пригадує, як вже з робочою візою та квитком не зміг виїхати до Польщі
через закриття кордонів.
Я заказав білет до Пшемишля попередньо
і чекав. 13-14-го я у понеділок хотів виїжджати,
а в суботу закрили кордони. Дуже це швидко було.
У мене була віза на руках, і я не зміг виїхати.
Приїхав через 3 місяці майже.
Але я ж кажу: це вдалося завдяки чартерному безкоштовному рейсу.
Такі рейси проіснували певний час, їх організували після низки звинувачень
на адресу українських урядовців у перешкоджанні виїзду заробітчан за кордон.
Коли був закритий кордон, ми замовляли чартери
і привозили людей на роботу літаками.
Для багатьох українських родин, особливо на Західній Україні,
робота в сусідній Польщі - єдиний шлях отримання хоч якогось прибутку.
Саме з Польщі, за статистикою НБУ, найбільша сума грошових переказів заробітчан -
офіційних та неофіційних. На польських будмайданчиках,
кажуть рекрутери, більше половини працівників - українці.
Після оголошення карантинних заходів у Польщі на початку березня
звідти, за різними оцінками, повернулися в Україну від 100 до 200 тисяч заробітчан.
Передусім ті, у кого закінчувався термін дії візи чи контракт,
побоювалися опинитися на вулиці та мати проблеми з законом
у разі повного закриття кордонів.
Це було пов'язано з дезінформацією,
адже Польща вводила деякі закони та інформувала,
що для заробітчан будуть спецумови.
Ішлося, зокрема, про автоматичне продовження
дозвільних документів на перебування і працю в Польщі.
Як нарікають міжнародні рекрутери, частиною проблеми стало і те,
що влада в Україні одночасно проводила кампанію з повернення українців
і працевлаштування на вітчизняному ринку.
Люди поверталися з певними очікуваннями.
Україна, коли звернулась до українців
з лозунгом: "Повертайтесь додому, ми забезпечимо вас роботою",
люди масово поїхали. Але коли їм  запропонували
саме ці вакансії - "Зеленбуд", будівництво доріг -
так, ці вакансії є, але люди звикли отримувати трошки інший дохід за цю роботу.
Нині, кажуть рекрутери, польські роботодавці вже адаптувалися до умов пандемії.
Вони влаштували регулярні автобусні рейси спеціально для заробітчан,
чого раніше не було, а також створили карантинні центри.
Водночас дефіцит робочої сили у Польщі не зменшився,
адже самі українці вже не так активно їдуть на заробітки, як до пандемії.
Тому що велика пропаганда йде
по українському телебаченню і загалом, що неможливо поїхати зараз на роботу.
Що це складно, карантин. І люди розуміють,
що треба мати певний запас коштів для того,
щоб відкрити робочу візу, відбути двотижневу ізоляцію за кордоном.
У нас на сьогоднішній день відкрито більше 600 вакансій.
Ось на зараз. Кордон, у принципі, відкритий.
Можна приїздити працювати. Єдине - треба мати, де пройти 10 днів ізоляції.
На думку рекрутерів, нині вкрай необхідні кроки
від української влади - це краще інформування громадян,
спрощення оформлення документів і перетину кордону
та міждержавні угоди в інтересах трудових мігрантів.
Таким чином влада суттєво допомогла б не лише заробітчанам, а й вітчизняній економіці,
адже мільярдні грошові перекази заробітчан також певною мірою її стимулюють.
Так, надходження до України від заробітчан
у кілька разів перевищують обсяг прямих іноземних інвестицій в українську економіку.
З 2010 року грошові перекази трудових мігрантів зросли удвічі.
Про це свідчить статистика Нацбанку України.
Цього року, однак, Національний банк України прогнозує
деяке скорочення обсягів грошових переказів
від трудових мігрантів - наразі на 4%.
Саме українська влада, статистичні організації прогнозують,
що десь 10 мільярдів доларів Україна отримає від заробітчан.
Але у зв'язку з тим, що українці не їдуть так масово за кордон,
я не думаю, що буде саме ця цифра.
А оскільки дані кошти до ВВП не надходять до бюджету,
це має досить негативні наслідки, тому що
коли в людей немає грошей, вони купують менше, вони заощаджують.
Інші сфери, які навіть не пов'язані з українською економікою,
також страждають від цього, оскільки
купівельна спроможність українців різко знизилась.
В умовах пандемії значною мірою від нинішньої влади залежить,
наскільки важливим чинником для України
залишатиметься трудова міграція у наступні роки.